okay I think we're dessert ready to
decide but everyone up there
hi everyone
good to have it so this has got us on
the screen good okay
it's an informal talk and the reason is
because the main reason I came to Oslo
this time was was MDC once again but but
this was us last night that the the the
Oslo Spektrum
yeah it was a great great event this is
that this is a picture I've been sending
to my arm to my family and threatened
service of a saw on stage okay let me
just let me just change something here I
want to put this on duplicate I think
that's someone I want
let's try this it's happening here why
aren't we on
sorry excuse me
what's on here try that here
alright ok we'll leave it like this ok
ok so it's a table for talk despite the
fact it's about user interfaces it's not
full of flashy demos at least it's not
full of my flashy demos because I'm a
programming language designer and not a
user interface designer and so but I do
have a little video of some some flashy
our UIs that are being done with the
fabulous framework but I'm going to
really talk about you know when you
build a framework you you you need the
framework and then you need a whole lot
of people who are actually really good
at using it and I'm the one who's kind
of building it we started it off and now
there's a whole lot of contributors
coming along and actually this is a very
much a community driven community owned
user into perspective on functional user
interface programming and it is AB is
one of the most enjoyable things I've
ever got to work on and that includes
f-sharp includes naired it includes
async and lots of other things but this
is something really gave me a really a
lot of pleasure to start start off this
project and I would love to get you
involved come and not only involved but
you're really helping drive the
direction of where this of where this
goes and completed out in certain
directions and build out the tooling
story and also to use it and have a
fabulous fun time so just to give you a
feel for some of the community who's
involved we have Jim Bennett is a myth
many of you know he's one of the great
evangelists in the.net space and in the
zamarons space as well mobile
programming now this talk actually seals
several slides and the video I mentioned
from Mark Malabon who's MVP in
Switzerland and you know he's a great
contribute contributor it also takes
inspiration from the work of Frank
Kruger and several other projects that
have come before that have started down
this direction and I feel that you know
things have really come together and
crystallized in fabulous okay so what's
the kind of context where I started this
work it is that when we brought F sharp
to dotnet did the man throw
as always we're going to bring
functional programming to dotnet and we
got to bring dotnet to the functional
programming world we're gonna get the
best of both worlds and that's kind of
the the driving spirit behind what if
shop has done and ever so much of what
you see in there you know if what makes
up that today generics is it was a part
of that story as well and so many of the
features that are in in c-sharp and the
ways of thinking compared to the world
where as it was back in you know 20
years ago where everybody was doing in
inheritance implementation inheritance
for absolutely everything hierarchical
classification for everything you know
they didn't all pointers back then and
see shops just trying to get rid of
those now struggling hard on that but
yeah we've we've come so far in in
integrating these worlds of practical
programming it's not net and functional
programming and mate and Franklin
proving that functional probe functional
first programming is an immensely
practical paradigm but we we've made
mistakes okay and one of the mistakes I
made or one of the holes in my knowledge
was I had no particular point of view on
functional first app development
application development user it we
always just said okay F shops for the
backend for the logic of your program
and you do your user interface in C shot
in c-sharp or visual basic or whatever
or JavaScript front upfront end and that
that's kind of there's there are reasons
we did that one is that the front-end
had this incredibly heavy tooling it
didn't matter which generation of
front-end programming you're talking
about whether it's Windows forms or uwp
or WPF for xamarin or whatever it's just
just seemed like this cornucopia of
complex tooling that was actually quite
technically difficult to make work with
a new programming language and so that
was one pragmatic reason but also we
didn't actually have a strong point of
view on what functional first app
development really even meant and it
wasn't until a language called Elm came
along the PRU that showed that
functional program
is immensely relevant to web application
development that I've realized actually
functional has a huge role in the in the
user interface as well and the Elm
inspired a paradigm or framework called
El mish which many of you will have
heard of which is used for web
programming with f-sharp and so that's
that uses a compiler called fable so
fable solves the user into Favell and
elements of the functional first
development for for web development and
both both client and server side and but
f-sharp devs also need to be able to go
mobile they also need to do you WP apps
a some old-fashioned ones might do you
know GT k app so they also need to be
able to do WinForms absented WPF okay
and we need to think about app
development so xamarin is a very
sensible place to start with this
because xamarin forms is an amazing
cross-platform cross framework sort of
unifying story for app development and
so we wanted really from the f-sharp
respective can we make xamarin a simple
and compelling v sharp up development
okay and it's good things have changed
since we started F sharp way back and we
have now this to this paradigm mvvm and
there are lots of mvvm frameworks in the
world there are very old ones like GT k
there are xamarin wrapping wrappings
around the Apple ones there's WPF is a
huge one we have an Android with VWP we
have salmon forms itself is an mvvm sort
of framework and you'll notice there are
lots of old fashioned icons over on the
left and they're all fashion because
partly there's a new new generation of
frameworks taking very different and
interesting approach
compared to mvvm we call these envy you
model view update and these ones over on
the right have these nice modern flowing
icons and there's a there's a reason for
this every doubt reflux we have react
native and we have react and we have
flutter and we have fable here and over
on the left what are the characterize
these oo programming absolutely you know
there's you have these generally complex
mutable models and view models
propagating changes through signals up
to a UI which is usually implemented in
a second language is declarative and
because it's in a second language it's
kind of static not completely static
it's got bits of knobs and dials and D
and turn things on and off and kinda but
anything that every any possible UI
state of element has to be lifted out of
the app and kind of sliced off and into
this static UI and it often yeah and
there's just there's this big trade-off
the reason they do that it's because I
want designer tooling but the designer
tooling gets very complex for because
you've kind of sliced off the user
interface out of your your code over on
the right these are characterized by
much more functional thinking much more
immune not always completely immutable
but much more immutability it's sort of
thinking or the view is a function from
an underlying declarative model and the
interestingly the UI is tends to be much
more declaratively dynamic I'll be
talking about Y in a later and the view
tends to be in the same language as the
DSL not always some integrate integrate
some markup and they take the the
tooling they use tends to rely on live
coding tooling which is relatively
simple has its glitches certainly
sometimes but it's but it's relatively
simple compared to the kind of complex
designer tooling fabulous for instance
which I'm talking about today the live
coding tooling is just comply
in the repository so if you want to help
work on that and improve it you're not
relying on a whole stack of tooling
provided by Visual Studio or or other
other xcode or other tooling
environments okay so things are changing
and let's take a look at these two
different settings I've described these
a little bit
we have view view model model and we
have this sort of data binding between
the view and the view model and then the
signals going back between the the view
model and the model and a and these
things are mutable and the view is
mutable and and then over on the right
we have MV you so you can do mvvm in in
f-sharp you can do it over the summer
and if you like and this is the sort of
thing that you you get can't can you see
my pointer no this is the problem I
don't know what I have to write so this
is this is what it looks like and as you
can see building a few model and
straightaway you've got oh my god you've
got mutation and it's ok it looks
actually quite nice it's quite ok enough
sharp to do for you if you have to do
mutable over program you said totally
fine paradigm to use for many many types
of programming but still the whole the
mutation is coming in very early and
very intrinsically in the whole
architecture of your application and you
get this sort of thing to kind of
implement triggers and property changed
event args and create commands and so on
it squander this mvvm world is not only
complex in its kind of in if
fundamentals of having this mutation
around but it's quite conceptually
complex as well you've got a lot of
terminology to learn like because the
user interface language has all these
widgets like these things commands and
and properly changed events and yeah the
underlying programming language doesn't
have those and you kind of got a meta
meta make those better and actually
create objects for commands and so on
and yeah ok so in contrast this is this
is how Model View update works you have
an online model you have a view
have a message and the message comes
back and the model gets incrementally
updated and then the view gets
rear-ended okay and this this confused
me like crazy for a long time I was I
was just like how the heck does this
kind of add up to how could so they're
actually really waiting the view on
changes to the underlying model and you
just suddenly you're all these warning
signs go off in your head isn't that
kind of flicker isn't that gonna be too
costly isn't that it's just not it can't
what can't anything flow back and and
but then but then through the there the
performance considerations are real you
have to incremental eyes things and
there's a whole set of techniques you
can use to incremental eyes this but the
fundamental information flow stays the
same and it's incredibly simplifying to
your that is only one direction where
information goes in your whole
application it's it's round and round
and round and you can individually unit
test each of these parts and each of
these parts are just functional
programming they're just functions the
view is a function from the model to the
view the messages are just functional
programming data discriminated unions in
F sharp nearly always and the update of
the model is just a function to update
one model to give you a new model you
can unit test those it's it is very
because it's information flow then it's
very few places for things to go wrong
in a sense so made mistakes of course
but but it the magic of functional
program is strongly typed functional
programming really begins to work here
and this is why Elm works so well its
wife elvish works so well and it's why
fabulous works well okay
so I've covered some of this just to say
a big shout out to the people who work
on safe stack some of them are here it
has really proven to me now safe stack
is a server side and client side with
favorable elvish but on the client side
and it really shows that non f-sharp
people have been able to pick up this
kind
the programming do the user interface
side of it in business context
you can talk to seven falkman about this
they find it really this is a really
simple end of F sharp programming okay
this is not that you don't you very
rarely have to define a type and if it
is it's just like a record or something
you you very very rarely have to do
anything difficult it's just absolutely
simple F sharp coding okay so let me
rant a little bit about zamel I can just
kind of let loose here like so I've
hinted that somebody's already some of
this way of thinking sam'l assumes
design is a sliced off the UI from the
code and therefore zamel ends up with
static it's got these layers of
complexity because it's not a
programming language they have to start
adding in all these programming language
features like templating okay and they
add in all these things that smell a lot
like code to me right behaviors and
converters and they have all this
complex design tool again it does fail
this tooling let's first be honest yeah
and separating the UI itself is fine in
this model the UI the model to the view
function is actually fully separated you
can carve it off if you want and put it
in a separate component or whatever unit
tested separately but do we really need
a fully separate language to do this
okay so this this is so sam'l ends up
rock layers of complexity and and to be
honest I will say something quite strong
which I feel sam'l is a bit of a
complexity disaster now that's a
stronger position that any official
Microsoft position their lives amel is
actually used effectively by by both F
sharp and C sharp programmers many many
applications are written in it but in
some sense it feels like a bit of a
category mistake in this dynamic UI
should be separated into a static markup
language it just doesn't
to me at some level I mean it's it
anyway this gives you an alternative
perspective on how that if you're gonna
do that slicing maybe you don't have to
sly students in exactly the same places
okay so let's take one example you want
to do a not Hatter not a binding in
zamel okay so you got ease enabled here
and you're it's late at night and you
try it in 2015 on the xamarin forms
forums and george cook here
thank you George is trying to know this
bit is how I want to don't know how to
do how do they were not in the user
interface not because they because the
view model which he can't change perhaps
has got is logging in and you want is
not logging in alright and what you need
is a is to one of these converter things
you know this is great today you got a
negate boolean converter with a novella
thank you Joe for answering the question
and button clicked on clicked image this
etc and then you actually have some
c-sharp code to return not here and you
can actually download a nougat package
for the negate boolean converter and I
think or collection of converters that
are commonly used and then of course
your app might get quite a bit bigger
because there's all these converters you
didn't need in there and on you go but
of course it didn't work because a good
answer but someone who's not much
familiar with zamel I need to add the
name space in the sam'l file to use that
converter that's good okay right fine so
just to say how does this look when your
view is a function from the model and
which is allowed to dispatch messages
this is a function view and it takes a
parameter model and it takes a parameter
which is a dispatch function allows it
to dispatch things and you can see the
few full view here it's a content page
layout and everything and at the bottom
we've got a can can you execute the
reset button and it's if the model has
changed but what if the view model said
unchanged okay well in the function you
just do that okay there let's look at
that again it's hard to find that on a
for romantic question because it's so
easy okay because you got to reevaluate
evaluate the view on each model update
then you just reevaluate this and you
differentially apply the updates on
there from the shadow view through to
the actual controls and and and the and
the and and a and E and the element will
will change from I can execute to not
execute so you're going from a world
where you need this sort of thing to a
world where you just code and just put
it in the not so how easy is that okay
so that's the inspiration what's um
what's needed the simplicity of fable
and elvish but for apps and this is I'm
just running you through some of the
getting started things so let's take you
through where we're actually at here so
we go to the fabulous website which is
heat on the FS projects incubation sharp
Community incubation site
they're heading very strongly to version
1.0 they're version 9.3 34 at the moment
with a with just a few items left to
knock off the version 1.0 and great work
by the team who are the community team
who are now looking after this okay so
here the docs have getting started
similar to here you just install the
fabulous templates and then you do new
fabulous app on some particular app and
then you land in a visual studio project
like this I've actually added a few
things here let me just sit down for
this
and because I'm getting old I have to
put on my glasses is this okay so I'm
also so I've launched this app and here
it is it's slightly modified from the
the one you get as you can see it's a
super flashy user interface application
here we'll talk about I've said I
haven't promised any flashiness okay so
the important thing here is let's take a
look let's uncomment some of this let's
comment out this here and will comment
out the smaller button okay just check
my yeah there we are so the okay I don't
have on top so I've got to this
yeah
okay so we run advisor on the right to
buy an Android phone here by Samsung and
we're using the live update tooling that
does come with fabulous you do have to
at the moment it doesn't launch
automatically you have to launch a
background process here and that will in
that will enable live update in your
application so you see you get about two
seconds turnaround time on our updates
to two to your app and the code is being
re compiled effectively rechecked on
your machine and a web connection is
open to the app running on the phone
which accepts a new chunk of code to use
as the as the logic of your application
okay so we have our code here so bigger
here so at the moment we can keep making
things bigger forever but what if we
want to put a limit on this so we want
to do that business of changing its can
execute behavior depending on what the
actual model is and we'll save that and
update and now when we come to bigger
and we come there the button is
appropriately adjusted for its logic no
data binding needed there just view
re-evaluation you can just forget forget
nearly forgot all about everything you
knew about data binding more or less
okay we'll add a new option called a
reset button as well and let's just
track through what the reset button does
here so there's a message type up above
I'll just skip forward to the very basic
structure that you'll see in every mvu
app we have the model here we have a set
of messages which can cause updates to
the model you have the initial state we
have the update function that was the
thing that comes back around to up given
the model and a message producer new
model and it's usually modeled with some
updates to the model you generate an
actual new model you can if you really
need to use mutable state in the model
you can do that but and just actually
change it but in this we're using the
fully functional approach here
and here's the view function it takes a
model and a dispatch like you saw before
and it can be dynamic it can the actual
content that you render in effect can
depend on the model state so if model is
pressed do something otherwise do
something else so this is compute the
view and that's it that's enough okay so
what have we got here we've got a reset
reset button and our visor here we could
go bigger bigger bigger and we do a
reset and we'll just double check what
happened there we are in the update
function it produces the initial model
here and also you can produce what's
called a command that's the only other
concept it's it's basically just an
action that happens an asynchronous
action that gets started as a result of
the update and can itself do further a
send further messages back around the
loop
okay so reset happened and it returned
the initial model of size two and we'll
see where that got dispatched it got
dispatched in the command to the reset
button
dispatch reset here okay so let's start
adding some new functionality we're
going to add a new game button but new
game hasn't been defined yet in our
messages type so we'll come back and
we'll actually define all of these
message types and will define what
happens in a new game it just goes back
to the initial model and I think we okay
I'll actually leave these ones since
we're not using these yet I'll comment
those back up and now we have a new game
which is more or less like the reset
button because it's actually more or
less the same i will uncomment
comment that out okay so let's start
adding some new messages here we're
going to what we do first we will put a
grid on here and initially we will make
it only contain box views and I will
comment out this code yeah and will lead
our helper function called make grid so
if you've got a part of your user
interface which recurs commonly you know
the object-oriented way of thinking
about it is let's make a class which
represents a new control because it's
going to have mutable state and so on in
order to capture that commonality and
that's why they start using
implementation inheritance to start
reusing fragments of of components and
user interfaces but in this world of
course everything's functional if you
what if you if you need to make lots of
grids in your applications then you can
just have a function which obstructs out
the process of making a grid because
it's just taking data the number of rows
and columns and a function to generate a
view element for that grid for that part
of the grid and you generate the grid
and then you just really use that in
lots of places so your your element of
reuse becomes just normal functional
programming and that's absolutely key to
wire to what is it's it's more it's more
productive because you don't have to use
implementation inheritance so we have
our nice blue grid now let's make it
that we're going to put an image on the
grid here take this now we'll need this
thing called solution here start
commenting these out
like all of these and think that's okay
so we've changed these elements all
going well now contains different images
for that for the different locations
okay right okay so let's now go the next
step which is to will initially hide all
of those images it's just actually I'm
gonna start I'll take the game over out
okay now we're going to have a message
to reveal an image here shout is
uncommon all of this
and hide okay before the game over
comment and we will put in a logic that
this line get rid of this line
okay so what's happening here so if we
or if we've already revealed an image
then we will show the image so that's
the dynamic part of the UI and if it's
not revealed we're going to use a gray
image and we're going to have a tap
gesture recognizer for when we tap on
the image here and then the image will
be revealed and you'll see is coming
through like this okay and then and each
second as I was tapping what was
happening we can just trace through the
flow of the logic it was sending a
message called reveal around the loop
which is here it's just one it's just a
date it's just data nothing complex in
that message revealing a position and
we'll see where it gets processed if
I've already made a first choice if I
haven't made a first choice then we
would just reveal the image and if I
have made a first choice while we do
some slightly more complex update
including that game over logic to say it
took me thirty seven seconds and now
because the user interface is dynamic
then the the business of how big that
grid is as a user becomes better and
wants to play a bigger game was handled
purely through the make grid function
which is just passing that model count
in and making just generating a bigger
grid and then the up there and then the
updates happened and I can smaller and
it comes back and that could be the sort
of thing which in zamel the move from
doing a static UI to doing a dynamic UI
it's actually a big a big change right
because the static LaMotte you are
you've hardwired or 3x3 or 2x2 grid and
so on and then to suddenly make that
dynamic it's oh my god what do I do well
in this setting it's dead simple you
just
you just just program it and generate
the different UI it and it's just this
instead of being you know four and four
here which case actually that doesn't
might yeah okay no that was right I
gotta check that anyway you get the idea
it's easy to make us make the UI static
and make the UI dynamic okay so that's
your sort of hello world of your dynamic
UI fabulous application looks a lot like
a favor a fable eldership and a lot like
an L map okay it's all functional
programming UI becomes information flow
view and model update just functional
programming views are recomputed the new
view is applied crucially for
performance applied to the underlying
controls using differential update and
if the view actually hasn't changed
there no updates are made and messages
are explicit and it's very easy to get a
full message trace and debug with
respect to what are the actual messages
coming through your application
okay so right that's not pretty so how
do we make it pretty first of all this
xamarin form supports CSS styling i this
these slides are taken from mark mallow
bones talk I'd strongly recommend you
you look at his material on using a CSS
styling with this kind of work I'm just
going to play a short video of of marks
marks one of the front ends he's made
using fabulous and I don't I haven't
listened to his narrative but my
understanding is this is it was a
comparative project versus coded UI and
this with using fabulous or using sam'l
and this is the results of the coded
coded driver just to give you some sense
of the dynamic kind of field you can
kind of get with your your your
application okay
okay here's some other apps that have
been written just give you the sort of
feel that what people are writing here
this I'll talk more about this app on
the Left this one on the right uses
these 3d displays called ohoo
a 3d display component Calder who you
can have Maps integration you have
charting integration and so lots of good
eye candy they're elvish contacts is the
one that was on the middle left and it's
an absolutely wonderful
I almost said absolutely fabulous
there's absolutely wonderful application
for learning it's got lots if you're
doing an information-rich application on
device sequel light integration these
maps I think data loading and all of it
just following the same kinds of
architecture and sending messages around
and all of it within the paradigm using
all these Amaral xamarin essentials
things sitting SMS phone calls mult it's
a multi page app which is it there's an
important technique I'm not covering
today by using these external messages
to reconcile the different components
and etcetera etcetera so that it's all
open source and you can help improve
that as a sample application and
actually use it yourself as your
contacts app on your phone if you like
so just to say that what is that view
DSL that we were using to describe views
it is actually very similar to zamel in
many ways you can actually do a
one-to-one translation between sam'l and
your view DSL you can start looking in
with sam'l that looks like this and you
get a view that looks like this then so
you can see how the the the structures
and names are all being carried across
so when it's complete with written so
the view DSL is everything that's
available in sam'l is available in that
view DSL but we strip out some of the
things like templating and the like so
not needed if you're interested in like
well how do you handle really enormous
lists of data that is covered on the
fabulous website that's the topics on
that
okay right okay so you might be
interested in animations like in react
obviously there's similarity with some
of this with react we use refs and so
you declare these things called view
refs and then once you have a view ref
you can trigger off these asynchronous
animations and either tie them into the
messaging model if necessary their
completion and the like or you can just
ignore the results in to say okay it's
got a the animation on that element is
going to run for as long as it runs
unless the LSL element actually gets
annihilated just because of some later
view update and then so we have a ref
here where you name it I'll point to it
here ref animated label ref and then you
dispatch the poked message and the poked
message check so we've got something to
animate and then it's triggers off the
animation okay multi-page apps yes you
can you still ultimately have a single
view function and it but it usually
returns one of these structured things
which is like a carousel page we check
so a single view function is specifying
all the possible pages of your app or in
the navigation it specifies the whole
stack of things so you've still got this
thing you've got a state of your overall
app and you've got projection to
multiple logical pages and each page has
its own model message and update
function and then you compose the pieces
just using normal F sharp code and there
are there are good examples of that as I
said so how do we make this efficient
well first of all the crucially the view
application to the actual view controls
is done differentially and incremental
update but if you've got something like
this and it can be very helpful to make
sure this part of the view doesn't only
gets recomputed if necessary and you can
do that by using this depends on
function and you list out the things
that it depends on in here so it might
depend on the model count and the model
step and they become available
internally as the counts and the step
and this model actually has a has a
different type now it's like do not use
me type okay so you can't actually use
the model internally in here anymore but
you can use the count and the step
so we use the count here and this means
that if the count on the step were the
same as the last time even if some other
parts of the model of the change if the
count on the step were the same as the
last time we actually don't don't do
anything okay
we we don't do any updates to the view
we just return exactly the same view
description as the previous time just
running through some pragmatics you can
persist state it's very simple in this
setting you just persist the model
usually serialize here to Jason you can
do it manually as well we don't do this
time-travel debugging it's actually very
very simple to implement within your own
app like it just go back in time please
through the app and that's use just app
set model and and it's a to a previous
model if your model it's purely
functional and doesn't contain any
mutable state if you interested in what
your app size is it's you just use a
standard xamarin linking and reduction
to get nice small apps
the core logic of your app is dotnet
standard 2.0 each platform you want to
run on it's something I haven't
mentioned by the way you can do gtk you
could do you WP you can actually do you
sharpen you WP apps for the first
realistically for the first time using
this framework and you can deploy them
to the App Store it's not fully
supported scenario by Microsoft that's
some caveats with that but it you can
they are saying yes you can do it on
your own it's around your own bat but
you do it and you can do WPF apps and
you can do window windows forms apps as
well okay you can pass in platform
helpers if there are differences you can
use platform conditionals and so on and
absol deployment just follows normals
Ameren processes just use the normal
everything that's normal in the docs
there's lots and lots of other examiner
and functionality xamarin forms
functionality developing around there
this new thing called shell is great
visual material is another one they're
all available on new good a thing like
xamarin essentials is ABS like it says
absolutely essential to get good work
done in app development and
nearly all orthogonal to the questions
of the view elements it's just things
like sending an SMS that it's just just
just works just like just like it should
so we what you might say can i define my
own view elements okay so for maps and
the like and yes there is an
extensibility story it's documented on
the website you have to write a short
amount of code to make that but I'll
just bring it up for those interested
yeah take a look at views extensions
here and there's a guide here for
writing of a view extension it will be
about about that much code for a typical
view extension and for example the Maps
extension is described here okay and
there are there are standard nougats for
maps for 2d graphics and animations and
for oxy for charting with oxy plot and
for 3d graphics with okay so that that's
most of what I wanted to cover if you
want to if you actually new to f-sharp
this is a fantastic book to get started
with get programming with f-sharp Isaac
Abraham read that first it doesn't cover
anything about fabulous and they move
over and get started with a fabulous
actually you don't even really have to
read this first you can probably just
dive into f-sharp with this fabulous
programming plus a plus one of the
others it plus the first few chapters of
a book like this okay thank you very
much and that's fabulous fabulous is a
simple f-sharp mvu app programming and I
said please contribute and get involved
thank you very much
[Applause]
have the other talks been taking
questions no yeah anybody a question
yeah here I'll repeat it once it comes
through
yes yes that that's correct
and there are important reasons for that
so let's go back and look at an example
about so the question is in in this
style of DSL that we've used
oh sorry can you put me back on that I
can point here yes we're using optional
arguments here so each of these view
elements actually have a very large
number of optional arguments available
whereas in fabulous it uses sort of
attributes like in like an HTML we did
this for a few reasons one is to get
very strong naming on the actual on the
on the arguments the other thing is
there's an important f-sharp compiler
optimization that applies which it takes
each of these view descriptions and all
the optional arguments and it actually
aligns it one step and they're actually
like 200 different possible optional
arguments and it reduces those down
because it knows you only specified
three and they can see that you
specified three attributes so it can pre
allocate an attribute property bag which
contains exactly the right number of
attributes and just fill them in very
efficiently so it makes the view element
creation highly efficient it says the
set of things that kind of happened to
come together to lead to this choice
it's also quite a nice ergonomic I've
got but I don't mind the way they did
that in in an Elvish it's just so this
also got us some performance goals next
question please
is there another yeah
yeah
the UI codes are same yeah yeah so I
should by default we only create the
Android and iOS because the others were
a bit fresh but if you actually want to
know the full set of platforms and
that's there so you can add WPF uwp Mac
OS and gtk and you get Android and iOS
so you get all of that the same
application code the same view code okay
yep
IIIi actually I did once do some try to
get the get started path on react native
and elvish and it I can't do a
like-for-like comparison Stefan falkman
it's a good person to ask he's doing
react native III with with elvish I mean
I think there he tells me this looks
pretty pretty good in comparison so I
yes you can do element react no defense
I'm very glad that we have both because
one's JavaScript base once thought net
based well yeah so I can't really say
this I think this has got a lot of
technical advantages but I'll just be
guessing
so yeah any one more question maybe yeah
it's the standard F sharp compiler and
the xamarin yep this is this is just you
you running using Visual Studio
on Windows you can do it a Visual Studio
Mac yep cool all right
thanks very much for coming everyone and
let's see we can talk more afterwards
thanks